this is the heading but once you've made
that hitting I'd like you to make a tiny
little adjustment because I think it
makes wills maybe you know that's what
they're called and it's what we're going
through today for something like the
most accurate description of what we're
looking at
he's how I'd like you to modify your
title index laws I think a really better
way of shameless is not index laws but
indexed shortcuts because that's what
these are when you hear the phrase index
laws I don't know what that it looks to
you to me really heat index laws I'm
kind of like oh you know you know you
better you better memorize these really
boring okay you better keep them
otherwise because there's laws you'll
face the consequences okay and laughs
when you break them all right so you
memorize who you have knowing and then
you have to follow them otherwise to
help you but actually I'll come to your
question in a second actually these
index laws right what they are is ways
to do things faster right ways to do
things faster that's what that's a short
cuts off right it's like look I can get
from cherry rook tapping and I can take
all the main roads and it will take me
this long but if you like a shortcut you
take some of the back streets it's the
same thing you're gonna get from A to B
but you'll get there much quicker okay
so that's what these index laws really
are they're shortcuts and we're gonna
look at the five okay now Daniel you
question memorize I don't keep a you I
keep laws that's what you do gloss don't
you so these are different columns okay
now we're going to begin and I'm
actually going to ask you to write for
me five spots five lines and we will
fill these in as we go
five index laws that we're going to
develop right index shortcuts you
already know two of them right now let's
take the call you and then we'll have a
look at some examples okay so here's the
first one
I'll give it to you as a law and because
you've seen this one before then we'll
give some examples off so if I have some
number and it's raised to a power
all right so a and M they're both just
numbers oh by the way and it's the power
or the index what's the a chord it has a
name yeah it's a base very good right so
you drop the base right now your vase is
raised to a power
if I multiply by another number with the
same base and its own power I'll just
wait to go it's not really that I might
call that much I can talk over you I've
loud enough it's just that you aren't
stopping everyone else from actually
concentrating that okay well
let's try it when you're multiplying two
numbers same base yeah is the same but
the powers are different right what do
we do to these powers it's going to be a
^ your moment
fantastic you add the powers you add the
powers okay so let's just give you a on
a quick example time for example okay
how about we do two qj-- which you can
work out right but that's not might be
interesting just yet if you multiply it
by two to the power of four okay it's
gonna be ^ follow the law it's 3 plus 1
which is 7 okay now remember it's not so
much that how long I've been learning is
right it's just that this is the fastest
way to do it it's a shortcut right what
would the alternative be the alternative
would be to say well what did these meet
what is too cute what is what is it
actually like not the value what does it
be yeah fantastic I mean 2 times 2 times
2 3 times right so I could do that I
could write that out okay and then I
multiply by 2 to the 4 which is the same
thing with an extra - 2 times 2 times 2
times 2 right so I could write that all
out and then I could count out 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 and say oh cool
it's 2 to the power 7 but how long did
that take right and if there were big in
numbers
it was ^ 8 I'm sitting out of 40 I don't
want to be sitting there writing 17
Tunes okay so this is just a faster way
to go about it fantastic this log here
right there the multiplication when you
multiply numbers the same base you add
the powers it's got kind of a up a
reverse twin which is when you divide if
you've got numbers with the same base
but different powers and you divide them
okay now just like multiplication and
division are opposites right here
I should have well what do I do with the
powers good I'm going to subtract
and buy this and okay again let's do a
quick example you can see what's going
on okay I could say 2 to the power of
5/2 squared okay now I'm gonna use the
law you can see it's gonna be 5 minus 2
which of course is just 3 okay then just
for the sake of illustration again let's
just do it out in longhand so we can see
what's happening okay to the power 5 2
times 2 times 2 times 2 times 2 right
just to make it super obvious when you
divide that's the same as a fraction
yeah I'm gonna put a big fraction right
there and how many twos well I have
other denominator two of them two times
two right so you can see just like with
any other fractions you can cancel
things you can't you cancel cancel you
do again yeah it's okay it's okay so I'm
only left with these three which of
course is to be cute but isn't it so
much faster to just go straight there
right the index shortcut is so much more
efficient